BeatとVue.jsを使って開発するための環境を整えたいと思います
Beat自体も実はJavaScriptで書かれているんですね
なのでまずはあなたのコンピューター上で
JavaScriptを実行することができる環境を作る必要があります
そこでインストールするのがNode.jsになります
Node.jsって何かっていうと
これは単純にJavaScriptを実行するソフトウェアになります
だからこれがないとブラウザ以外では
あなたのコンピューター上ではJavaScriptを実行できないので
同時にBeatも使えないわけですね
だからまずはNode.jsが必要です
でも今これNode.jsの公式のページを開いているんですけれども
もしNode.jsをインストールしたことがないという場合は
まずはこちらのNode.jsを入手をクリックして
例えばこちらのインストーラーをダウンロードするなどして
インストールしてください
その上でもう一つ必要な作業として
エディターを用意するというものがあります
エディターってのは何かっていうと
文字つまりコードを書くためのツールになります
エディターにはいろんなものがあるんですけれども
Vue.jsは公式でこちらのVisual Studio Code
Visual Studio Codeと言ったりもするんですけれども
こちらの使用を推奨しています
なので特にエディターにこだわりがない方は
Visual Studio Codeを使用するようにしてください
もしまだVisual Studio Codeをダウンロードしていない方はですね
こちらのボタンからダウンロードしてみてください
で開くとこんな感じですね
さあでは早速Vue.jsとBeatを使って
アプリケーションを作り始めていきたいんですけれども
実はBeatやVue.jsを使うには
その準備としてHTMLのファイルを用意したりとか
専用の設定ファイルを用意したりとか
結構いろんなファイルを最初に作る必要があります
ただそれで結構大変なわけです
なので実はVue.jsは公式に
Beatを使う場合に必要となる
そういうたくさんのファイルを一気にまとめて作ってくれる
コマンドを用意してくれていたりするんですね
ちなみにコマンドってのはこの上のですね
Vueのターミナル
私はよくショートカットキーで開いたり閉じたりすることが多いんですけれども
ここで入力することができます
でじゃあそのVue.jsが公式で用意している
ファイルとかを一気に作ってくれるコマンドって何なのかっていうと
npm create view at latestというものです
こちらですね
Node.jsがインストールされていたら実行できるコマンドになっているんですけれども
この状態でEnterを押すと
こんな風にVue.jsのタイトルが出てきて
いろいろと聞かれます
例えばプロジェクトネーム
今回は何でもいいんですけれども
Vue.lessonとかにしておきますね
この状態でEnterを押します
そうすると次プロジェクトに以下の機能を加えますかと聞かれます
こちらは矢印の上下で移動できて
スペースで選択をすることができます
でAのボタンでトグルオール全てを選択して
Enterで決定できます
それぞれこちらはどういう機能かというと
TypeScriptはJavaScriptに型を付けた言語でして
構造の最後の方で改めてVue.jsと一緒に使う方法について解説します
なので今は使えません
最新の情報になります
収録後にTypeScriptだけ
最初に別に追加するかどうかを
Yes,Noで聞かれるようになりました
講座通りに行う場合はJavaScriptを使えますので
Noにしておいてください
でJSX
これはHTMLのような構文を
JavaScript内で書けるようにする機能なんですけれども
これもですね今回は使えません
でRouter
これはより複雑なシングルアプリケーション
SPAを作るためのものになります
でPにはState Management
つまりプロジェクトが大きくなった時に
データの状態を管理しやすくするためのものになります
この2つもですね後半のセクションで改めて詳しく説明します
でBテストとEndToEndTesting
これらはテストをする時に使う機能になります
でESLint
こちらはコードの品質を保つためのものでして
入れておくとですね
コードが正しく書けているかを事前にチェックして
簡単なエラーを防いでくれたりします
なのでこれはスペースを押して入れておきますね
ちなみにそういうツールのことを総称して
Linterと言ったりします
最新の情報になります
こちらの表記がESLintからLinterに変わりました
それに伴ってインストールされるLinterが
ESLintは継続してインストールされるんですけれども
それに追加でOXLintというLinterも
同時にインストールされるようになりました
なので2つのLinterが一気に入るということですね
そのOXLintは最近できたんですけれども
Beatなどを作っている団体と同じ団体が作っているもので
ESLintよりも何十倍も早いLinterになります
ただ最近できたこともあって
ESLintほど全てのパターンを網羅できているわけではないので
主にOXLintを使って
OXLintがカバーできていない部分を
ESLintがチェックするというように
2つのLinterを使ってエラーを防ぐようになりました
なので出来上がるファイルにOXLintの設定も
追加されると思いますが
そちらはまた後で紹介したいと思います
では講座の続きをどうぞ
次Pretia
こちらはコードフォーマッティング
つまりコードをきれいに整えるためのものでして
こちらもですねスペースで入れておきたいと思います
でEnterを押しますね
次にですね
実験的な機能を入れるかどうかを聞かれるんですけれども
ここはですね
まだ安定した機能ではないので
何も選択せずにEnterを押します
最後ですね
コードの例を全てスキップして
空っぽのビューのプロジェクトを作りますかと聞かれます
これはですね
結局作られたサンプルコードは全部消すので
どっちでもいいんですけれども
今回ですね
そのままノーにして
一応消さずに作っていきたいと思いますので
このままEnterを押します
そうすると
ビューレッスン
プロジェクトネームのところで指定した
名前のフォルダが作られまして
その中にですね
いろんな最初に必要なファイルが
全部作られるようになっています
ちょっと分かりやすく
VSコード上で見たいので
こちらのファイルのオープンフォルダから
そのフォルダを指定してみてください
そうするとこんな風に
今作成したビューレッスンのフォルダを
VSコード上で見ることができますし
こんな風にいろんなファイルやフォルダが
今の一つのコマンドで
作られているのが分かると思います
ちなみにここですね
おすすめの拡張機能みたいな
ポップアップが出るんですけれども
これはまた後で解説しますので
今は一応×で消しておいてください
追加の情報になります
最新のクリエイトビューのフォルダ構造は
こんな風にファイルがネストされて
表示されるようになっています
こちらはですね
こちらの.vsコードの
セッティングストットJSONで
VSコードの設定をすることができるんですけれども
ここにですね
ファイルネスティングという設定が
追加されたことによって
このような表示の仕方になりました
なのでこんな風にグループ化されて
綺麗に整えて表示することが
できるようになっています
ただこれはですね
VSコードの表示の仕方が変わっただけで
ファイルの構造自体は
講座の内容と変わりませんので
ご安心ください
最後少し余談なんですけれども
このファイルとかを作ったコマンド
このコマンド1行で
厳密には何が行われているのか
っていうと
実はCreateViewという名前のパッケージ
ソフトウェアの最新バージョンを
インストールして
その上でCreateViewというコマンドを
入力するという処理が
このNPMCreateView
atLacestの一行のコマンドで
行われています
だからこの一行のコマンドは
CreateViewというソフトウェアを
インストールして
CreateViewを使うという
だけの意味になります
つまり何が言いたいかというと
こういうですね
ファイルがいろいろと作られているのは
CreateViewというツールの
おかげなんですね
だからもしCreateViewと聞いたら
こういうファイルを作ってくれるツールなんだな
ということをですね
ざっくり思っておいてください
さあではそのCreateViewが作成してくれた
このファイルやフォルダが
それぞれどうなっているのか
これをですね
次のレクチャーで説明したいと思います
ご視聴ありがとうございました